こんにちははじめしゃちょーです皆さん
通行人って知ってますでしょうか
愚問ですね通行に皆さん街とか
学校の帰りとか仕事の帰りとか歩いてる時
に人とすれ違うことありませんかよく東京
とかだったらもちろん人も多いですし
田舎とかでも絶対おじいちゃんとかおばあ
ちゃんとか自転車乗ってる人とかって
すれ違うことあると思うんですよ
気にしたことあります皆さん通常に気にし
たことあります
僕はありませんありませんけどもなんと
なくねかっこいい人が通ったらえかっこ
いいとか可愛い人が撮ったらえ可愛いとか
通行人とすれ違う時なんやかよ思うこと
あると思うんですよ皆さん今回はそんな
我々人間という生き物が通行人に対して
どれくらい意識を向けているのかの検証
実験してみたいと思います今回の検索する
ために特別にエキストラの方に来て
いただきましたお願いします
[拍手]
みんなボーダーというわけで今回赤白の
ボーダー服を着た老若男女16名準備し
ました
ありがとうございます
なんかすいません今回の企画は今から
ターゲットと僕が一緒に
撮影関係なく普通に道を歩くんですけども
道を歩いてる間にボーダー服の人と連続何
回すれ違ったら異変に気づくのが検証して
いきたいと思います
[音楽]
ちょっとキャラ付けさせてもらいますわ
じゃあスーパーナルシスト君だね
やんちゃ坊主のお母さんみたいなあんた
今日も宿題やってないのちょっと言い合い
ながら歩いていただけると
助かります
リストラ寸前のサラリーマン
落ち込みながら歩くかはい
君たちどうしようか小学校のお友達に
しようか
うん2人で仲良く歩いてね2人は
大学に馴染めてない陰キャ2人組でお願い
します
3人はもう本当今から行くか楽しみだね
みたいなもしないというみたいな感じで
ございます
えーっと
ギリやる気のおじいちゃんのお願いします
ちょっとヨボヨボというか
えっと
交際して1週間目のカップルなので
あんまりそのラブラブっていうより今日
ちょっと楽しい日だねみたいな
絶妙な距離感だよお願いしたいと思います
ここの美女でお願いします
ラーメンみたいな感じで
歩いていただいて見ちゃう感じとかね
ちょっと
誘惑してくださいよし
完璧なラインだったら
皆さん
早速練習してみたいと思います
えっとあの人が手あげたら一番ミスター
落としてくださいそれから前の人が行って
から6秒後に
歩き出すという感じでどんどん行って
くださいはいというわけでここから
ターゲット僕が歩いてきますそしてこの道
にボーダーの人が10連続出てきます
じゃあちょっとデモンストレーションで
やってみますね
[音楽]
もう違和感ヤバいけどちょっと待ってやる
前から俺の目やばいんだけどもう
仕掛けられてる側の気持ちになってやり
ますね
ボーダーの服着てるな
[音楽]
お
[拍手]
じいちゃん遅すぎて
詰まっちゃってる
なるほど
これ気づかないっすね
僕が見た体感だと200%バレますが
うちの後輩なめないでください今から来る
後輩さあでもう目が本当に
望遠鏡のあのプラネタリウムとか見る
ぐらいの視野の狭さなんで多分気づかない
と思います早速やってみたいと思います
[音楽]
おマジちょっとスマホボロボロなの
いいロック画面じゃんじゃあ
SIMがもう完全に壊れてるってこと
これは大丈夫ですただ
ログインしないといけないなんか壊れて
なかったっけ
裏とかボロボロだった気がする
やばすぎでしょ
かっこよくないんだよね
なんかそこの公園めっちゃ変わってるの
知ってる
変わってるらしいよ
[音楽]
見て空の今日この
色いやめっちゃマジで綺麗です最高だね
最高っすねそこサウナになるらしいよ
すごくねだってポケないなんか
整え部屋とかじゃないかな多分ね
めっちゃヤバいっすね
そことかの
らしいよ
すごい
可愛い
[音楽]
でっかいパラシュートを上げるっていう
どうした
イメージが
そういうこと
服装がみんな一緒だったって
気づいた
気づきましたおじいちゃんに気づきました
最後まで気づかなかった最後まで気づか
なかったです明らかにおじいちゃんそんな
格好しないじゃないですか
ないですちょっとこれまだ検証電車あり
そうですね
絶対バレると思ったけどラストまで大丈夫
だってだからそうですねまだあのバカな人
たち俺の周りたくさんいるんでちょっと次
も検証してみたいと思います
[音楽]
竿のすごいいつからできんだろう
今度は
すごいのほらそこの
同じ書きだってサーベル友達がやったん
でしょお前のところ
スマホどここうやって見してや
確かに新しいやつはないの
楽しいやつはもう使えないのに
アップルの人じゃない
ジョブスやジョブスジョブス
差し替えてこれでまたさあでも使ってんだ
え
向こうになんかそんななんか
春のイメージするとこある
気づきましたか
絶対のボールでしょ
ウォーリーではないんですけど
連続で何回赤白ボーダーの人が横切ったら
気づくの
2回目で気づいてましたはいというわけで
確実にバレることが分かりましたので
ちょっと作戦を変更したいと思います
通行人に気づくか気づかないような検証な
ので次からターゲット止まらせます
ターゲットが止まってる時にそこに赤白
ボードの人が横切ってて気づくか気づか
ないから検証していきたいと思います
[音楽]
やばい
んだっけどっちか
[音楽]
あれ
をしましょうあれ
流行ってるはい大事だはい
気づきましたか何だろうなんか
靴紐子を結んでて
チラッと見たらなんか
視界に入るのが
赤と白のボーダーでおかしいなと思って
これ目立つ服もあれだったんかね
通行人が10回連続ボーダーの人だったら
気づくかどうかという検証でした
えじゃあ
着いた時から
常に通ってたあーもう何が通ってました
結構ちまちま出してたんですけど最後の方
も結構ドワーっていっちゃったんだよね
なるほどそこで気づいたところがいや一人
ずつだったら気づかんよ俺
[拍手]
[音楽]
不可ボーダーが流行ってんのかあー
ちっちゃい子
[音楽]
両家の
親族がいや
[拍手]
みんな同じ服着てますけどね
気づかないのかな
恥ずかしくないのかなやっぱ大家族おじい
ちゃんいるな
[音楽]
違う団体